teniendo un posible auge en la llegada
de inmigrantes indocumentados Estados
Unidos reforzará de manera temporal su
pie de fuerza militar en su frontera con
México
1500 soldados adicionales llegarán a
partir de la semana próxima Para apoyar
a la patrulla fronteriza durante 90 días
estos 1.500 militares que procederán del
componente de servicio activo cubrirán
lagunas críticas de capacidad como la
detección y el seguimiento desde tierra
la introducción de datos y el apoyo a
los almacenes hasta que la protección de
aduana y fronteras pueda atender estas
necesidades mediante apoyo contratado
esta decisión llega a pocos días de la
expiración del controvertido título 42
el próximo 11 de mayo una medida
implementada durante la administración
de Donald Trump que permite la
deportación automática de los migrantes
que intentan cruzar la frontera
terrestre estadounidense argumentando
riesgos para la seguridad pública
consecuencia de la pandemia de Kobe 19
las autoridades temen ahora un repunte
de las llegadas de migrantes a su
territorio por su parte el presidente
mexicano dijo que su gobierno respeta el
despliegue de los militares
estadounidenses en la frontera pues es
parte de sus facultades es un gobierno
este
independientes soberano ellos toman esas
decisiones y nosotros las respetamos
Estados Unidos hace frente a un flujo
migratorio inédito con más de 2,76
millones de indocumentados interceptados
en esta frontera en 2022 como parte de
la estrategia de Washington para frenar
la migración irregular y fomentar las
vías legales se anunció la apertura de
centros migratorios en Colombia y
Guatemala